je vais en prendre qu'à moi même c'était
un certain 18 août multi faisait beau
c'était période un peu festif de l'année
voilà plein été quand donc je rentrais
d'une soirée il était à 4 heures du
matin un petit peu éméché nous faire un
peu picolé qu'en plein été
gg temps t-shirt j'avais le casque en
mai vont protéger mais c'est tout
audionautes écurité pas de gants rien du
tout en scooter
j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone j'ai
voulu regarder ce qu'il en était donc
j'ai baissé la tête pour regarder le
téléphone quand j'ai relevé les yeux m'a
j'avais changé de direction et du coup
j'ai dévié ma route et je tapais en
larmes
aia c'était un petit scooter c'est un
scooter 50 donc j'étais à 60 kilomètres
heure environ et est donc j'ai tapé un
arbre au niveau des cervicales
ici donc sa fracture c5 c6 donc ce qui
veut dire estimant tétraplégique
j'étais élagueurs donc métier super
physique serait pas mal de sport je
m'entretenais pas mal et puis sinon
franchement j'adorais ma vie je donnerai
ma vie c'était plein de trucs toujours
actif pas toujours rage au jeu vidéo et
c'est pendant des heures et des heures
est serré du coup l'accident ça par
rapport au mode de vie que j'avais avant
j'étais obligé de complètement tout
reconstruire
autant jamais bien faire de la moto
sortir le soir
et voilà que la plupart des choses que
je faisais avancer des choses que je
peux plus faire aujourd'hui quoi c'est
vraiment c'est en fait c'est quand on ne
peut plus ancien maire qu'on se rend
compte de la poule f faire le corps
humain ce qui on peut faire avec dix
doigts en contrôler 10 en même temps
cédé 10 interactions simultanées c'est
hallucinant et nous maintenant cagoulés
doit complètement plié mois on a quoi on
peut faire 2 3 2 3 bidule en même temps
mais ça rien à voir avec voilà là je
fais un petit peu d'informatique avec le
clavier mais c'est vraiment c'est très
très compliqué on papier que sur une
touche en goûtant comparé à avance qu'on
était capable de faire ne viennent voter
comme ça c'est français voilà c'est vrai
qu'on sait quand on la sait quand ça
marche plus qu'on se rend compte du
l'efficacité de la chose cantonnement si
c'est de transmettre le message que
voilà la route ça fait des dégâts très
sérieux et et que même si on ne meurt
pas sur le monde
il ya aussi ceux qui qui survivent mais
mais qui galèrent en fin de compte astro
mais tf1 serena dans une vie normale